alexander ocasio-cortez uh she is uh out
to
make a quick buck off of her
sloganeering nonsense
so one of the great things about
capitalism is that socialists love
making money
off of capitalism everybody loves making
money off of capitalism
so alexander ocasio-cortez started
pitching her new line of gear
now she's a congress person okay like we
here at daily wear we sell gear too
for example we have a new sweatshirt we
have a new sweatshirt
that we are going to discuss in just one
second at daily wire but that's because
that's what we do for a living
and alexander ocasio-cortez has her own
woke store
so a couple of examples from the woke
store for alexandra ocasio-ocasio cortez
so she has a sweatshirt the sweatshirt
says tax the rich upon it okay and this
this sweatshirt
tax the rich with a little aoc slogan
over there
i mean this is this is a great buy for
you okay it's available at the alexander
ocasio-cortez store
the lady who hates capitalism and says
it's exploitative and evil
it is made in the united states it is
union printed is 100 cotton it is a
gender neutral fit
it says tax to rich it is 58
58 i mean
what a deal so you can demonstrate how
much you hate capitalism by spending 58
on a sweatshirt tax the rich the only
person who can afford this is somebody
who's rich
can you just imagine a bunch of poor
people who just spent like half their
daily salary minimum
on on a tax the rich sweatshirt to pitch
aoc's brand of bullcrap
it's amazing like good for her seriously
anybody can make it in america it's
pretty fantastic
okay and um i i did offer an alternative
to the tax the rich sweatshirt by the
way
we decided not to go with it we went
with a different sweatshirt here at
daily wire
um the the one that i suggested in
response to tax the reach uh taxed the
rich was um leave me the
loan but we decided not to go with that
one here at daily wire instead
we went with our response which is
cheaper than aoc's
garbage sweatshirt it says insert woke
slogan
because i mean we'll charge you less for
that and that way it serves all your
purposes right you can do all the same
things that alexander ocasio-cortez
wants you to do right you can signal
your support for a bunch for a basket of
crappy policies it is also 100 cotton it
is also made in the united states it is
also a gender-neutral fit
and it is cheaper than aoc's socialism
sweatshirt because it turns out
that capitalism is always better than
socialism free markets drive down the
price and increase the quality
tax the rich is not as good it's not as
useful as a slogan that says insert woke
slogan
because he ours it's appropriate for any
occasion if this insert will slogan
sweatshirt and then
if it's black lives matter today it
doesn't matter you don't have to change
your sweatshirt
right just count it says tax the rich
today doesn't matter you can still wear
the insert woke slogan sweatshirt and
you are good
to go okay but i just love the fact that
alexandra ocasio-cortez
critic of the evils of capitalism is
selling on her website a 58
sweatshirt that says that says tax the
rich
spectacular spectacular okay but that
was not
that's not the only stuff that that aoc
is selling on her website
she is also selling a t-shirt it is a
t-shirt
of herself it is an imitation of a
painting
called the green called wanderer above a
sea of fog this is a very influential
romantic era painting
in which it showed originally a man
standing on a rock
looking over a sea of fog and the basic
idea was that
enlightenment ideals could allow man to
scale the heights and then survey the
vistas
so alexander ocasio-cortez being her own
biggest fan
has now commissioned a painting of
alexander ocasio-cortez
standing on that same rock looking out
over a beautiful vista
like the cover of the pocahontas vhs
and above it it says the green new deal
that one
will only cost you 27 so you can love
aoc nearly as much as aoc loves aoc for
just
27 okay also she has put out
a great t-shirt it says student debt but
it's crossed out
that's all the t-shirt is it first of
all you could get this for like seven
bucks on amazon
should be real about that this is like
the cheapest t-shirt in history to
produce it's one color doesn't have
multi-colors on it any case
it's a student that but it's crossed out
with a black line
so instead of paying back your student
debt instead of taking that 27
and paying down your debt and being a
responsible person since you voluntarily
took out the debt in the first place
instead you could give aoc's campaign
27 to promote her bull crap and never
pay back your student loan debt
sounds awesome okay but that's not even
the most expensive item
in the aoc market okay the most
expensive item
is this extraordinary sweatshirt from
alexander ocasio-cortez just a wonderful
sweatshirt
social economic and racial justice
okay those are just words thank you for
that social economic and racial justice
aoc okay now um i'll it will
all it will cost you to demonstrate how
virtuous you are by wearing a sweatshirt
that says social economic and racial
justice
all it will take you is a 65
nothing says economic justice and social
justice like spending 65
on a sweatshirt nothing that is stellar
stellar stuff
the entitlement mentality of the very
critics of capitalism who then use
capitalism in order to make bucks
is pretty it's pretty spectacular stuff
and the self-pitying nature of all of
this is also pretty spectacular
aoc sees herself as this messianic
figure inside the democratic party she's
going to push
for hope and change and barack obama
true fashion
but she also really pities herself a lot
so last night
she tweeted out the thing conservative
senators don't seem to understand
is i've actually had a physically
difficult working-class job without good
healthcare
most of my adult life i bring that work
ethic to congress and my community
they sit around on leather chairs all
day yeah she had a tough guys because
she was a waitress okay so my dad worked
in a restaurant for
20 years 20 years and most of the people
he was friends with were waiters and
waitresses
and that is in fact a difficult job and
guess what
a huge number of republicans did not
start off the center actually you know
who
has been sitting in a leather chair all
day since 1973 joe biden
joe biden was elected to senate in 1973
so she might want to direct her
elsewhere also quick note on aoc
you gotta love the political incoherence
of alexander ocasio-cortez
calling for medicare for all she says
she didn't have health care right
that she's had a physically difficult
working-class job without good health
care
most of her adult life okay alexander
ocasio-chris is
she's 31 years old she's 31 right that
means
that in 2010 i think her birthday i i
looked this up
yesterday for purposes of the suite uh i
believe that her birthday was
some time in october i think so she's 31
years old
that means that she was 20 when
obamacare passed i thought obamacare was
going to solve all of our problems guys
i thought obamacare was like the
greatest thing to ever happen to
healthcare she has
been her entire adult life living under
the auspices of obamacare
so what is she talking about she doesn't
have health care i thought obamacare
solved all the problems
no subtle slap it barack obama there aoc
okay in any case is this coalition
capable of being held together
i don't think so i think they've got
some real problems inside that coalition
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content